hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything
Annamayya manga and today what we have
is a first impression of fire force the
series that has been much anticipated
for the season along with dr. stone so
before we get into things just to lay
this out right at the outset I have not
read the fire force manga and as a
result I know absolutely sweet FA about
anything this series has to offer other
than what I just saw in episode 1 and I
don't plan on reading the manga at least
not until this initial season concludes
so we're looking at this from the
perspective of someone completely new to
fire force and after the opening episode
I have to say that I am very much on
board and I'm glad because I wasn't
really sure what to expect jumping into
this despite the fact that fire fighting
is one of the most noble professions
there is I would not have thought it
would be a great focus for a long-term
Shonen series but of course anime cares
not for my own creative thoughts and so
fire force has spliced a huge spiritual
element into things without protagonists
not just facing off against flames but
infernals spontaneously combusting
humans have become for all intensive
purposes from my perspective at the
moment fiery demon things this idea is
also reflected in our protagonist Shinra
who i was quite hesitant about after
seeing the key visual for the series and
stupidly enough it was because of his
smile it struck me as a very traditional
annoying shown in series brat who's
going to be super over-the-top and all
Yelly but I loved that that thought was
completely smacked down immediately with
this episode the whole involuntary smile
is such a neat idea it's actually
something's currently being explored in
one piece and it's capable of generating
tragedy so effectively through the
juxtaposition of this simple facial
action for example in this opening
episode what probably hit me the hardest
was shinra's flashback specifically with
his grandmother and then when it cut to
him smiling demonically but on top of
that just knowing the pain and suffering
that this kid must be feeling through
that it was heartbreaking as well as any
portion of flashback featuring Shinra
and his mother playing hero because
society here seemed so set up to
immediately classify him as the villain
I mean you've got the smile not to
mention the shop shop thief's and on top
of that he can even conjure flames which
seems to be seen as the great enemy of
the world so and it's not a wonderful
start to life if your goal is to become
a hero
of course shinra's tragedy runs deeper
than that with the death of his mother
and brother for which he seems to be
blamed for it along with that we also
had this stunning shot of an incredibly
ominous looking fire bro which was great
because it really gave me those
exaggerated Soul Eater vibes which was
an aesthetic I adored for that series
but the author looks to have toned down
and
for fire force but all the lore
intriguingly this is also accompanied by
silhouette image of Shinra throwing out
the question of did he or didn't he
potentially even implying that he has
some kind of grand force within him
outside of his control whatever the case
is definitely something special about
the kid which makes sense he's a
journeyman character and all as for the
rest of the main cast they're a bit more
difficult to judge at this point in time
because it was a very Shinra heavy
episode as it should have been at the
moment my favorite is probably Aki taru
because he strikes me as a strong leader
despite the fact that he doesn't seem to
have any special pyrokinetic abilities
there was also Tucker heesu who has a
serious stick up his ass for which I
imagine we're going to discover the
reasoning behind and he's like super
super intense size and overall he's a
pretty good balance to a Qatar is more
laid-back nature I will say that I'm not
entirely convinced by his weapon of
choice being the Uzi like gun and that's
because despite the horrific power in
reality that is very rarely conveyed
through animation or even film and more
often than not just sounds like it never
really has any effect plus it just
doesn't look cool to hold I mean you've
got this super amazing in serious
character with a bulky bulky frame due
to the coach holding this teeny-tiny gun
thing there you know isn't going to do
any serious damage to what if the big
that is
so if taka hiza is the like firearms
dude and I'm hoping that he has other
weapons of choice and this was just a
bad first outing with us but if I
remember correctly he's also a
pyrokinetic yeah so I don't know it just
seems like a bit of a waste to have him
wielding guns but then again what do I
know I'm just some schmuck who's only
seen the first episode feel free to
change my mind enemy rounding out the
team we also have two female members who
of course were more or less introduced
in the traditional female way with a
communal shower scene at the moment I'm
more drawn to marki because she exudes
that sense of fun and also she's
absurdly shiny I mean just look at all
those light bounces she must be
permanently coated in oil however I'm
also intrigued by iris if only for her a
specific role on the team which I
believe is existing to facilitate the
spiritual passing of defeated infernals
or something along those lines question
mark I'm not really sure because maybe I
just missed it during this episode but
if she does have any spiritual abilities
I don't see them just shots of her
praying so at the moment she very much
represents religion in the real world
needing to take a leap of blind faith
rather than being shown in any sort of
proof I mostly find her presence
interesting though because it
potentially places a strict condition
under which the infernals can be dealt
with like will the team refuse to take
out an infernal without iris air to
offer a prayer for the soul in question
or what happens if there are two
infernals and iris can
to deal with one there's some
interesting moral questions that have
the potential to develop as a result of
the focus on the salvaging of souls and
it seems religion in general certainly
can't be ignored in fire force but with
their entire facility being in a
Cathedral and all and this is a side
note I've only just seen this but I
really enjoy how the five full station
is just sort of graffiti'd onto the side
of the cathedral which brings something
else up I'm curious as to exactly why
these guys have been thrown into such a
place
the infernal seem to be an incredible
threat to society at large one that only
a very specialized group seem capable of
dealing with so you'd figure that they
would possibly get some more decent
funding for their base of operations
yeah I'm sure that's something that will
be explained in time like maybe there's
a societal prejudice against what they
do or if selecting that Cathedral was a
choice made by the team itself for its
spiritual significance by the way it's
mildly intriguing as is the world in
general I do quite like the aesthetic
presented in fire forces a lot of care
and detail that has gone into making it
feel like a well lived in world which I
appreciate and I cannot wait to learn
more about the history of it as well as
the infernals and speaking of I've
brought them up many many many times
already but I haven't commented on just
how fantastic these guys look in both
cases during this episode I felt it was
a bit of a shame when the infernals were
defeated because I just loved looking at
them so much the primarily black figure
shrouded in flames as a treat for the
old eyeballs and actually just the fire
in general was handled so damn well by
this first episode and you Tobit would
be given that fire is in the title of
the series and the basis of seemingly
everything but it was nailed and full
credit to David Productions for stepping
up to the plate and crafting something
that beautiful speaking of David
productions were a company I was quite
unfamiliar with up until watching this
first episode and upon looking into them
they haven't really done a whole lot
outside of the Jojo adaptations which I
haven't seen but from here on out I will
be keeping a close eye on this company
so in the end fire force did pretty much
everything I would have wanted to series
opener to do it gave us a compelling
protagonist a solid setting an extended
cast for the nice chunk of potential and
brilliantly animated fired e-mini things
so as a result I'm in hit me with
everything you've got
but with that said I'm still not sure if
I'll be doing weekly reviews on it so
let me know if that's something that you
would like to see but that pretty much
does it for my first impressions of fire
force if you enjoyed this video and the
content this channel produced in general
then please do consider donating to the
new world review patreon because the
support of all of your amazing people is
what continues to make this channel
possible and if patreon isn't quite your
style then please do leave this video a
like share or subscribe because it also
but this channel an incredible amount
and if you'd like to join the fun at any
time then please do head over to my
discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan retakes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your thoughts on fire force this has
been the new world review and I'll see
you next time